working with the time to graduate
students at Princeton and kitchen
Raphael wall Hill on some algebra
complexity question actually having to
do with not commutative circuits since
started with the Amelia die-off
fantabihooby swells also here and we
somehow ended up needing to understand
this environment here we a lot about
invariant theory and this we for years
have been very enlightening for us and
productive for us and we also
collaborated with a bunch of other
people some of them know must know about
this dis field and to break geometry and
presentation theory then as we learn a
lot from them and what I want to share
with you today is I'm not going to talk
about our work much and talk mainly
about invalid theory but the perspective
that I got into it through this work and
I want to really convey to you how how
closely related this field is to us and
you'll see lots of examples there will
be lots of examples in there in the talk
you don't have to you know follow every
example read the details of every
example but you'll see lots of familiar
familiar objects notions results that
will ring with you I hope you know in a
way that will they also about relate
there you'll see the relationship
between these two fields and in fact
there is a lot that happens in volunteer
way that is so close - well I know
instincts I think that there's a lot to
learn from them and there's also a lot
to contribute to them know collaborate
with them and I hope this will be will
become clear in this talk I want to
start with a bit of actually
an image and I will take just take a
chair just in case I just feel that it
may be may be needed so and sorry about
that
this is happened to me already once
before when the last few months if I
[Music]
want to start with a bit of some pre so
it's a personal plea story but somehow
how I something that suddenly get into
these questions and these connections
but when I years ago was working with
the Natalie now there are some more
lately on some problem that I'll show
you and we developed this really cool
algorithm in terms of the school
algorithm was discovered numerous times
before in various contexts it's very
important but I will not be the focus
and I will tell you about this algorithm
and maybe that's the only algorithm you
see what's the problem is a matrix
skating program so you have a
non-negative matrix and you like this
one
Jason C matrix of some graph happens to
be and you want to make this matrix
doubly stochastic so you want to make it
for sums 1 and column someone and what
are you allowed to do where you're
allowed to multiply rows and columns by
constants that's what you are allowed to
do and it's not clear what how to do it
because they're the interfere columns
and rows but there is a very natural
thing you know the school algorithm is
really something that comes naturally
it's sort of greedy and maybe naive and
stupid if you think about it but you
shouldn't think about it you should just
write okay let me fix the row so they
are stochastic that's easy right okay
but the columns are not so then you say
okay let's do the columns and now the
columns are fine but the rules are not
fine so then you fix the walls again the
columns again if you also can see what
happens it turns out that this is what
happens in the limit converges anything
this matrix which is doubly stochastic
and it turns out to be a theorem that
this converges if and only if the
permanence of the matrix was positive
mainly if the the draft associated graph
at the perfect matches and in fact if it
converges it always converges fast for
normal time so this means that this
algorithm is probably one if you've
never seen it before is a very different
algorithm for perfect matching that is
not normally taught in you know in
classes but maybe the simplest to
program it just two lines so that's one
facts about this and the other facts in
this paper of the nothing the harlotry
we had an analysis for which that was
somewhat different between us analysis
and at the time we had no idea but now
we understand much better and the right
way to view their analysis and
understand this algorithm is to involve
you and we understand it better
so see
so the outline of the talk is I want to
tell you about what what invariant
theory studies of some of what
involuntary studies their motivation
their questions their results the notion
that structure in though that they
developed and it has two parts
which interact really well algebraic
part in a geometric personality part and
interact very well and increased when
you get to this optimization and 180view
I thought the end I'll explain about
this magical moment polytopes
and I've talked just a very little about
algorithms and then it'll be motox in
the workshop and hidden by the file that
you'll hear more about is these
algorithms and some of the other words
that's related to this project
I would say connections between
complexity and optimization within
valency oh yeah so that's a plan
then stop me with questions we do it
studies symmetries group actions orbits
invariants and it occurs all over
intense applications all over now in
mathematics and physics and computer
science so here are some examples so you
have a group and you have it has to act
on some set of objects for example the
symmetric group he'll act from the
labels on the names of the vertices in
graphs that's a very simple action we
know very simple to describe here the
group is just the real line just time
acting on the set of configurations of a
billiard table ball then it evolves over
time and disappear and this reaction
that's a nice one he reacts on just
plain of configurations by scissors and
movements of pieces around
and in each of these so there's motion
there's action there's dynamics right
the group is really simplify scoop
operation things are moving but some
things don't change
these are invariants that's the way
invariant theory then well invariant
comes in for example in the last example
the area doesn't change as you cut and
move things along non overlapping you
know in the billiard we know it's a
physics example many of these processes
preserve things like energy momentum and
so on such things these things don't
change in the case of this graphical
model and we don't really understand the
invariants out there but we don't
understand them and computer science I
didn't test physics and math you but we
know this dynamics just computer
programs they evolve the values of
variables and often we analyze them with
invariance right we keep track of and
that two Scrolls will will be very
relevant to the analysis well the
returns that we'll talk about okay so
that's a very very high level view we
will look one of the top at very
particular types of actions the groups
we will look at linear groups and I
wrote ill examples of the linear groups
we we will talk about so that will be on
the ball you know them all
you don't have to think about others the
general linear groups of all non
singular matrices and it subgroups
especially now go for all the terminal
those with the turnip one these are non
abelian groups you have the building Dux
which are the same only that you allow
only diagonal matrices so the tools is
just non zero values on the diagonal and
the special sauce is non zero values on
the diagonal determinant of one and
we'll just look at you can think of just
these groups all the examples will come
from these groups of products of such
these are the only things you'll see
even though the theory I'll talk about
is much more general it applies to all
that
oops and if well this mapping I'll tell
you about is rational so let me talk
about what I mean by this linear action
here so the linear action is just that
you want to think of your group whatever
it is as a group of matrices and you'll
see example you're already familiar with
but in general the way to think about
group as matrices is to every element G
in the group you assign the assignment
matrix which acts on this vector space
so the action is always on the bottom
objects you move in just vectors in the
vector space vector space over a field
which for us where the top will be the
complex numbers okay and so what does it
mean that every element is represented
by my matrix if this satisfies what you
wanted to satisfy that you know these
matrices when you multiply them compose
like the book elements and you have an
identity and you have an inverse and
here are examples you are familiar with
let's say G is a symmetric group its
acts on the backs of SN it's actual
vectors of length n by permuting the
coordinates so this M Sigma force
permutation Sigma just the permutation
matrix is another one general linear
group acting on a vector space of
matrices now by conjugation let's add
interaction right
it's an interaction all the matrix acts
and I want to splice you that here the
number of coordinates X is n square
matrix is n by n but there are n scruff
coordinates are moved about so you can
know sometimes think about when this is
represented like this X is a long legs
off and square coordinates but it's
concise represented this way okay so
these are examples of interactions and
here the objects the main objects that
are being studied in this type of
actions they are so the first things to
notice when you act on a vector space
and your Pearson coordinates for this
last row space you can think of them as
variables
so you're acting on the variables and
their value are also acting on
polynomials in this variable okay so the
first object and very important objects
is invariant polynomials invariant
polynomials are executive polynomials in
these variables which remain unchanged
under this section that's why they'll
call invariant
the second is Oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you
start from the vector and you apply the
of the goop elements to it so you get
everything you can reach using the goop
and this is the discord and all bits are
represented by possibly for vector V and
it will be very important because we are
working over the complex numbers over
any continuous sort of field that we
look at all these closures so sometimes
this set of points that the group gets
you to is not closed in the usual and
it's very very important to take
closures so that's the closure of an
orbit it does take all the limit points
of this set and you leave many talks
during this conference well this thing
will be important okay so these
obviously and let me give you some
examples that again you are familiar
with of these objects if Jesus and
acting by permutations and the
invariants develop polynomials you know
what they are they're the symmetric
polynomial there cause symmetry because
it's a symmetrical you don't care about
the order of variables in the polynomial
where are two vectors in the same orbit
if they have the same number of
components of each value like then only
then can the group of one to the other
and what about closures well it's a
finite group so you don't have
everything is discrete Euler very close
to the edge video check it's my I always
live on the edge
[Laughter]
second example so we saw this
conjugation example let's see what of
the these objects here turns out that
the invariance already seen generated by
the traces of the power of this matrix
you don't again you don't you don't see
it don't matter it's just we're doing
some things for maybe college algebra
with you
so all be it's actually our job done
normal forms that's what variants are
not polynomial invariance but they are
invariants and all these closures yield
I fell from of its I mean that we don't
have to go to into this but it depends
on whether the matrix is diagonalizable
or not but if you want to test whether
to omit closures intersect or not what
you have to test is whether they have
the same eigen values eigen values also
involve you're familiar with them they
are not polynomial in values but they
are determined by this polynomial okay
these things you've seen and in fact we
have all over the place examples of this
yeah we mentioned graph isomorphism
where the action is a symmetric group
where we see where we problems actually
include you know maybe not explicitly
but I include questions about orbits and
all these closures and the relationships
so graph isomorphism is an obvious one
relations very question about tencel's
rank and border rank of 10 volts if you
look at three tensors
it's very no rank is not affected if you
act by change of basis in any one of the
three dimensions so you have the natural
action there I want to say that symmetry
is a care in lots of questions whether
or not you explicitly acknowledge e in P
I T is the same we are asking rather
symbolic determinant is zero then you
can change bases on the Left change
bases on the right or change basis of
the variables
testing again it's underlined for
property taking of grass fields metal
group codes module and these students
and his colleagues you know study the
fine group acting on clothes when you do
property testing and the importance of
that and you'll hear a lot in the next
talk and also later how in the study of
arithmetic circuits or the Mickey versus
P and P questions in the DCT program we
want to know whether you know the
question really is whether permanent the
polynomial is in the orbit closure of
determinants of appropriate size and the
group action is again the same we are
linearly on the variables right and it
moves these polynomials about and this
is a group action but I want to stress
you that it's this group action did we
keep talking about algebra this is the
notion of reduction in algebraic
complexity oh this leaner change of
basis in the variables so there's a very
strong connection intuitive and the high
level connection between what
environments are studying what we are
studying it somehow aligns perfectly
okay so these are the reductions and it
happens to be the arithmetic complexity
the reductions are do factions are very
close to blue patches here's the objects
that is the first I want to say some all
about so we talked about the environment
polynomials it's clear that environment
angles are closed under addition
multiplication so they form a ring so
that's what environment I'm to
understand it's denoted this way so C of
V the ring of Palawan polynomials and
you put a little G on top all the
environment nominals
and a fundamental maybe they are say the
big bang of the field even though it
started these papers of Hilbert well the
main thing he wanted to prove was that
this ring in the generality I talked
about reductive personal representations
in this very general setting is finitely
generated so you
I always describe it's infinitely many
polynomials but you can always describe
them by finite set and everything it
generates in the algebra setting is sort
of remarkable that lots of things you
know about lots of things that were so
important for mathematics commutative
algebra and also for us like the most
are adults and the tiny bases few of em
and also algorithms like the table basis
algorithm have you know started that it
you know things that Hilbert needed to
pull as maybe lamar's I noticed to get
this environment theory result and they
became I would say maybe even more
important than in mathematics and this
result and what invent yeah question
but in theories okay so just examples in
the case of symmetric group then you ask
what generates or symmetric polynomials
when you probably know they are
generated as an algebra by what we mean
by the elementary symmetric polynomial
just a finite set in the case of
conjugation these places of powers are
generated just by the powers up to n by
the cayley-hamilton theorem so you know
that and in fact it's very important
that the set is is small and in fact
it's bounded by if you look at as SN or
GL n is the degree of these polynomials
is bounded by n is you know just a
finite set small and also low degree
happens to be just happens to be the
case in where first is the size and is
the number of things you acts on in the
second is a dimension of the group so
it's sort of not clear what n plays well
in place but a very fundamental result
so one thing they are trying to do in
variance here we get the great bound for
the generating invariants and that's
improves a very important Co and much
improving on on hill belt that you can
always bound the degrees as a
exponential function of n let's say
the dimension of the group will be
mainly interested good like that we will
talk about this later so that's the
environment and there's a high-level
comment is that not only our structural
bounds are important for in value to
environment but also algorithmic bounds
they care about algorithms and there are
books in which argue essential
computation is in the title and there
are explicit algorithm they need to and
in fact you want to solve systems of
polynomial equations you want to compute
you know generators in an ideal and so
on you need and these are for even
particular actions that you want to
understand you need algorithms that
since the middle of the 19th century
they have been developing that
for any any you know reductive book any
rational action rational representation
of the group is of dimension n the there
is a set of generators all of them of
degree at most exponential in n we
generate the whole environment and you
cannot improve in this generality there
are some that require the main problems
sort of computational problems they look
at computational problems and structural
problems you want to describe all
environment these generators the
relations between the generators you
want to get the Gribble's as I mentioned
which is simpler problem and then there
are all these isomorphism problems that
we started talking about before where
are two things the same under the group
action is isomorphism problem so we want
to understand maybe whether two orbits
intersect or bit closures intersect
you'll hear in Katherine's talk about
natural normalization and it's the
generators problems he'll describe it
orbits closure containment and for the
rest of the talk I'm going to focus on
one problem with simpler than all of
them it's already extremely rich which
is this malcolm problem the narkom
problem is all these problems where one
of these orbits is the orbit of the
point 0 of the vector 0 you notice it on
in all these interactions when you act
in 0 on 0 you get 0 back so 0 is always
in an orbit by itself and you want to
know whether another orbit is similar to
it let's say orbit closure contains 0
that's right now comprar blame and I'll
just talk about this and you'll see how
familiar it is in so many ways
how generalities you know it captures so
many things that we care about so I want
to start giving you example questions so
far
okay let's look at the Newark on public
so he will come to the geometric point
of view so we have this go p-- action it
induces it creates is set of orbits and
the geometrical analytic point of view
of environment i'm to understand what is
the you know what is the space if you
contract every all these two points what
does it look like you want to projective
eyes the space somehow in particular you
have to understand what is like zero for
for this for this purpose who looks like
zero who touches zero and was sort of
separate okay so i want to tell you that
captures many natural problems again we
have this goop action reaction v we have
the närcon like all the all the vectors
v that the group can take close to zero
and close to zero in the what's a
closure what does the closure mean that
there is a sequence of group elements
that will put this vector to zero okay
so that's what we try to understand this
nut cone and what what kind of problems
does it capture it looks very you know
particularly at this point but you'll
see in a second why not so for my
analytic point of view in fact
optimization point of view this question
is like this review of xov and to tell
you whether it's in an arc on you ask
whether we can get close to zero so it
might as well look at the norm of this
work so can you make it as small as you
want by group by sequence of group
element what's the infimum of our group
elements of this norm of this vector
does it get that's the analytic view and
is an algebraic equivalent you know
condition for testing whether it's in
the in the Northland which this is it
turns out to being an Ultron exactly if
and only all environmentally no meals
evaluate to zero at this point right and
One Direction is very very simple
just because polynomials
continuous the other direction that
requires the challenge at sea land and
other stuff so that's a very important
theorem it's important because it
provides this important connection
between the algebraic and analytic sides
of invariant theory and for us it
provides a connection between the
optimization problems optimization
problems and algebraic complexity
problems and we see this like created
problems come up you'll see now in the
mo in Kaitlyn's talk and in the file
stock how P I t enter C so that's a
really important message that this
connection and this connection invariant
theories knew about and they use it and
we also use so here are some examples
which have many examples I just want to
show you the null cone in some situation
so what's the dark corner of the group
action the symmetric group acts on by
permutations when can you get zero
volume you can get zero any of your
coordinates so now justice is by itself
and there are no closures here because
the finite group in the case of a
configuration that we saw we said the
invariants are generated by the traces
of powers of the matrix and here it
turns out and you may or may not see the
närcon contains all the important
matrices one important matrices they can
be pushed to zero by conjugation and the
others you know another familiar object
you we learn lots of these things in
college algebra we never talk about
group actions we talk about yeah but
they arise naturally here's another
example if you instead of conjugation
which is multiplied by matrix a means
inverse you look at this left right
action you multiply on the left by one
matrix and the other by another so
change racist independently then he'll
the invariance of the frontal generated
by a single polynomial just the
determinant of the
and here the null cone is not important
matrices but singular matrix as it turns
out very natural object of flow and I
will come to familiar things like what I
showed you in the beginning matrix
scaling so here so there is a group
action which I sort of didn't mention of
though it's obvious when I said you
normalize those and normalize currents
by constants it's just you pre and post
multiplied by diagonal matrices like
this so that's a group action there is a
group action that this algorithm was
really implementing so it's not the
basis change just multiplication by
diagonal matrices it turns out and raise
it to see that the environment you are
generated by these monomials which are
just matchings
right if you look at any particular
product like this if you we and cost x i
the angle matrices of determinant one
you are not changing any of them that's
simple and then our cone turns out to be
exactly those matrices for which
determinant is 0 so this is you know
with direct connection to the perfect
matching problem so perfect matching
arises naturally here we saw it already
but it's just an Archon problem perfect
match
it's a now condition from where is which
if you can it's good action to look at
for this purpose but you can get it also
if you don't do the tournament it's sort
of choice you have a graph it has a no
perfect matching if and only if the
matrix is touching machine is an outcome
problem
here's another even more important now
control
that you are very familiar with and this
would be say well execution say what
this is a now from problem so here's
another home problem for you the next
but this is very important to me and
that's how this project started in fact
when we looked at this section each
other of this to this it turns out to be
in some sense the quantum generalization
of the previous problem doesn't matter
how here's the various natural action
instead of acting on matrices you act on
tuples of nexuses so we have n matrices
x1 to XM and you act on them by pre and
post multiplying them by basis chain
simultaneous bench basis change okay on
the left and on the right so you see the
action is right this wpm force multiply
each of them by matrix and yielding
variance turns out to be no not so easy
to find it took a long time in this
sequence of works and they are generated
by an infinite family of polynomials
these polynomials are the determinants
of this sum of tens of powers and they
are parameterized by this di so you take
matrices the eyes of all sizes and you
know each of them will give you
polynomials in terms of these variables
excise and it turns out that all of this
polynomial generate the in valantine the
null cone here turns out to be very
interesting and much first itself in
many areas of math and going through
quantum information theory it
corresponds to this non commutative
singularity problem it relates to an
alternative identity testing and other
things that I'm not going to talk about
so you don't have to understand this but
it's very rich and
the first result we started this results
it started this with this paper with
fire and heat and long it groove it and
followed up by different algorithm
advanced Subramanyam the deterministic
polynomial time algorithms to understand
to test membership in this knowledge and
this algorithm used the Dirksen bound I
mentioned on experiment exponential
terms out exponential decay bounds were
good enough for us it's not clear even
why it's relevant but it's very relevant
to efficiency analysis and for the
subsequent result it was using the
stronger result longer bound for this
action you can get polynomial in n
degree bomb that was very important but
one point to make in this algebraic
workshop is that this testing here is a
very interesting sub problem of the
polynomial identity testing question
which is different than the type we've
been looking at for many years like
polymer identity testing for various
class restricted classes of circuits
this is a very structured and different
kind of p80 problems and we know how to
solve this and others efficient in
deterministic polynomial time this is
what I wanted to impress you with also
the linear programming problem is a is a
knockin problem so what is the action
and what are the what is the action on
here the action is of this tools right
just a diagonal set of matrices just one
matrix not how does the does it what
does it acts on it adds so much the
vector space the vector space of all
polynomials but let me allow polynomials
with negative exponents or one
polynomial and
the action is the simplest thing you can
think of is scaling it just like we were
scaling matrices we are scaling
variables so when we have a matrix like
this so just a bunch of diagonal times
t1 up to TN we just scale its variable
exile scale back here this is reaction
you start with the polynomial you get a
different polynomial so we look at the
action on the coefficients of the
polynomial that's a lineage and now if
we take any polynomial and its support
let's say I'll just not let's say the
support is just a set of coefficients
which are nonzero and you want to know
what the null cone of this right is this
polynomial is a vector you want to know
whether it's in the natural order
well you are really asking this problem
is not in the nut clone if and only if
is 0 the point 0 is in the convex hull
of the support of this polynomial what's
the support again support is a set of
exponent vectors so you have this
collection of integer vectors these are
the exponents appearing in your
polynomial it's a bunch of points in
space you look at their convex hull the
convex hull is called a Newton polytop I
never knew why anybody would care to
take the set of exponent vectors of
polynomials and take their convex hull
this turns out to be very important
algebraic geometry it helps counting
number of solutions to systems of
polynomial equations but never mind that
you see that this object is not in the
NARC loan exactly if a linear
programming problem of membership
problem in a prototype is answered yes
so it's a very natural way in which
linear programming arises from a very
simple group action on polynomials yes
that's not yeah
I'll answer you right and it turns out
that there is a non commutative analog
of this which we will see later and
we'll see a non commutative so this
things that naturally arises in in right
theory is also the study of non
commutative analogs of in our
programming when they have results which
will soon see about this and there you
know that we didn't know about I didn't
know about and it's very
very powerful you can be complex set it
but it turns out it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter at this point yeah but at
the end what you will really look at
these polynomials with non-negative real
coefficients that's what the actual
polynomial care about will happen for
many of the further all the questions
are interesting over finite positive
characteristic finite trees we know much
less about them about many of them and
yeah so I restricted myself to this
because that's the reach of it was a
beautiful questions there so here's a
complexity theory view of the what I
want to tell you about this närcon
problem where is where does it lie well
what's the complexity in general I've
given you a bunch of examples but where
does it lie it turns out it's morally
it's in NP intersect 20
and in fact we'd like to make this small
alley into something more concrete
yeah geometric invariant theory you
don't remember all the acronyms from the
previous slide what do I mean by this we
I mean what we usually mean in
complexity of Indian country and country
we have easy proofs of membership and
homeland membership in there in the
närcon the two major results were the
hit but Mum fault criterion which tells
you how to certify membership and they
kept last year when we scheduled to
self-certify non-membership and I want
to tell you about both okay so we have
sort of easy proofs but they are not
quite polynomial time in our language
and sometimes you can make that I and I
just mentioned that of course other
things were more earlier we have decided
kind of characterizations of stalin's
are positives tunnel dots and we are
trying to make would make them you know
into MP and country and actually
these statements so I do okay sorry I'm
full one I'll give a couple of examples
and then talk more about the second what
they Hilbert manful criterion how to how
do you certify that an element is in the
lock on when you want to refine the
sequence of elements that drive this
vector v2 zero okay would be nice if you
could do this bigger restrict your space
of sequences and you can what they tell
you is that you can restrict yourself to
a compact description because you can
restrict yourself to a sequence of
elements that are just parametrized by a
single parameter what's called the one
parameter subgroup of whatever group you
are working with this is no loss of
generality reason the null cone is there
is a single parameter subgroup so just
mapping from the complex numbers to your
book the index elements they are driving
it to zero you don't have to follow the
you know the next I'll just give some
examples of one parameter subgroups but
they're familiar where you may be
familiar with them
if you group is just that the complex
numbers under multiplication and one
parameter subgroups are just integer
powers of parameter if you look at the
Thomas you know you have n of these guys
then one parameter subgroups are just
you generalize the previous examples
it's just diagonal elements where each
one is the same T to some integer power
if you have the special tools in which
determinant a one then you impose this
condition that the sum of the a is are 0
because you want the product to be 1 we
see this coming up in a second and for
noncoms non abelian groups it turns out
that one parameter subgroups are really
easy to understand and that's very
important although we won't see it they
are just the previous example only
change by a basis just you pre and post
month that's all there and the fact that
you have this description is extremely
important anyway you don't have to
remember this it's just examples
I want to give you the example of Nexus
scaling in this context of this one
parameter sample because this really
what brings up the connection between
the närcon of this action and the
bipartite matching it turns out that X
is in the null con exactly we will see
why because of the parameter sample but
this what comes out it's basically when
this linear program is solved this comes
out of this one parameter sub of
characterization and you know this linor
the 7l program that tells you that this
happens exactly if there is no perfect
matching so support is just a non zeros
of this matrix so this comes out just
from the in Batman force criteria and
let me not do it but you know this
follows directly from what happens when
you know that these are the one
parameter sample and that's what it
means to derive something to zero you
get this you know very network so that
was the example I want to spend more
time on the campus condition which is a
condition showing that an element is not
in the null cone how do you certify that
well we said already that in order to
know that something is not in the not
only just have to find an environment
for anemia which does not vanish on this
point that's an algebraic condition and
I would say that till this set of works
the airport to check this was in fact
running through in algebraic direction
but then the analytic condition which
was known but probably not applied I'll
go it makes it very much is that it
provides a much more efficient way so
let's see well we said that oh it may be
let me make these definitions we are
trying to check whether within the
närcon so we are trying to find whether
way
the group drives it 2-0 drives it's
known to zero so let's define this
capacity of the groove it's he called
capacity in a different context but now
we are using it for all these actions
the capacity of V is how small can you
make V by plying elementary but what's
the minimum norms plan on you can make
it so here is the orbit of V and you are
trying to move along the orbits and make
it as close as you like to zero and we
are asking about non-membership so we
have asking about separating it from
zero and so if you can make it zero then
it's in the NAR column if it's positive
then it's not in the not gonna turns out
you should think about like you think an
optimization when you are trying to
minimize it
when is it minimum here you are just
trying to you know compute gradient and
see what is zero and turns out it in the
virginal setting gradient has a
different name it's called the moment
map it's called the moment map and you
are trying to say whether this let's
call it a gradient I'll define it
whether it's zero or not and it turns
out that this is equivalent this happens
to be equivalent to the question of
whether we can be scaled in the sense of
what we talked about scaling matrix
scaling an operator of scaling a
polynomial scaling arises naturally from
this context well in the stories I told
you before it arises just of various
optimization problems that people were
studying but it arises naturally he'll
okay and minimizing this this moment map
is a dual optimization problem to
minimizing capacity and there is in fact
a duality theorem that we'll see that's
camp nastier
okay what's the moment map the moment
that is really the gradient of this
maybe non commutative action so what you
are trying to say is what what is the
gradient you just want to understand how
an infinitesimal action around the
identity I'm not doing anything that's
the usual definition gradient of the
derivative affects the norm so that's
all the norm is affected by invested in
festival infinitesimally change around
the identity you should reduce in
gradient so it's a linear function on
some space this space is you know maybe
not our energy all familiar with but it
happens to be the you know the lie
algebra of the group but you don't have
to care about this let me point out that
it it occurs in more general settings
but I'm not going to talk about it but
anyway as I mentioned before minimizing
this gradient finally out when it's zero
is a scaling and I'll show you examples
of this how does the group structure
affect what possible directions you
think of it as a gradient but I imagine
you have to buy the direction where the
determinant is 1 so you don't have to
worry about it as it turns out this Lee
algebra of the group it's just an inner
space it's a tangent plane to the if you
if you want to as identity to the
manifold which is your book it will be a
linear space is parametrized just like
RN is parametrized by n coordinates but
in the case of GL n for example it will
be just MN all N squared entries will be
an N squared dimensional space
you have to somehow understand this but
it will be a little it would be a little
functional like your favorite dragon so
maybe the kind of question that I think
Russell is asking is are we going to be
non-uniform with respect to the group
and uniform with respect to the vector V
in terms of the other associated yeah
absolutely so we fix the group action we
fix I know like matrix carrying is a
general thing we know what the action is
and I will give you a matrix can it be
scaled or is it in the null time yes
reason and yeah we'll see even more
inputs yeah
so matrix scaling again you know this
this is a calculation how to get the
moment map you did not lead just to show
you that it's a simple calculation from
the definition of derivative and what
you get out of it is this you know what
what's this gradient it turns out to be
should be a vector it's like in normal
gradient and this vector is determined
by the wholesome than the column sums of
the input matrix it turns out that in
this description is all sums and column
sums in in l2 but it doesn't matter you
can change it and the other thing is to
have these shifts by constant one we are
all arise naturally and this is scaling
to a uniform marginal we are asking
whether zero whether this equals zero we
are trying to make this equal zero so we
are really trying to scale the matrix
this comes out naturally from the
direction just an illustration we are
looking for scaling of the matrix which
gives you you know uniform mountainous
here's another one the scaling of
polynomials actually yeah let me let me
skip it but anyway very simple
calculation tells you that you know what
the what is gradient is and test to do
its optimizing
right okay I want something else before
I'm done so lots of natural you know
this arises naturally and shows that
scaling is a natural
in the case in the context of a
geometric environmentally and against
elements to the general theorem what
they tell you is that when you want to
certify the non-membership of a vector
in the null cone you have to produce
another nonzero vector right on which
the gradient vanishes just like we are
used to in the Euclidean setting and
this theorem has two directions the easy
direction is we want to if the element
we find this non zero vector is 0
gradient that's as close as we can get
to zero that separates so this is sort
of an instance of showing that a global
minimum is a local minima that's the
obvious that's the direction and this
direction is of course the opposite so
the other direction is showing that
local minimum implies global minimum and
in the Euclidean setting we know it I
mean this is all about convex function
so that has to be some convexity when
the actions are of this type of the
abelian type then it really you know
follows from normal convexity you have
to do a change of variables that move to
geometric programming for those who know
but anyway this is very easy and natural
and in what these people have done it
also shows that this is in holes with
much more generality only that the
convexity that exists there is geodesic
convex here simply have to you're
working in a different in a different
metric but the same philosophy holds
this picture is the same the local
minimum implies global minima
Congrats ET arises naturally in this
setting so here's an example again made
to scale in the I mean I just repeated
myself but I want to stress these two
conditions we saw using hilbert mum fold
that that's where the X is in the närcon
is the same as testing whether the
support is has a perfect matching and on
the other hand
testing that X is not in the null
using the campus condition it just
testing whether you can scale the matrix
to having a young uniform marginals to
doubly stochastic they arise from this
theorem and this you know this was of
course known in optimization but it
follows out of this general c1 and I
want to hear the last five minutes I
want to talk about this point so we are
scaling here we talked throughout about
scaling to uniform marginal why in fact
in optimization people keep scaling to
mean this theorem is much more general
you are suppose I want different
marginals what happens then so let me
tell you what what happens then and
again in various theories knew about
this this brings us to the last topic
which is the moment
polytop saying I'm giving you a row
targeting the column target and I want
to get as close device just bite you by
fiddling with the rows yeah multiply
rows and by constant is a very natural
question it arrived so what we should be
looking at we looked at the gradient and
we asked when it was it's zero but in
fact let's look at all the gradient
satirize I mean 12 points so you know
all the day so let's call Delta the set
of all gradients so we look at all
values of the moment map over all points
in the space it's a set let's look at we
can also look at all the gradients that
arrived in an orbit right we are given a
point and we look just at the orbit and
we look at all the gradient these are
two natural sets of Corrections of set
it turns out that this is a huge result
and I think surprise definitely to me is
that all of them if you properly you
know normalize and stuff all of these
are not just sets there are convex
polytopes
they're all convex polytope they are
called moment polytopes and then the
uniform scaling problem we saw is just a
question of whether zero is in this
moment polytop
and the non-uniform scaling problem I
refer to having other marginal just
asking about another point maybe our
whether it's in the moment pollito
that's what it comes out to be it's a
membership in a polytope favor
so role in our programming problem and
some of this work had led to algorithms
and applications I have just an example
again with no need for matrix shading so
again as I mentioned you want to scale a
matrix by changing its multiplying by
constants to achieve particular set of
marginals here and of course it's a
linear programming problem but this set
of marginals is was known by the same
theorem wasn't know that the set of
margin as you can get to by scaling is a
convex polytope I should stress it's not
to about the set of matrices you can get
by scaling that's not a convex set
but this is a convex and that's just a
special example and this is a special
case this Mesa scale in fact is a
special case of just marginal problems
you know you have the distribution
satisfying some conditions on its
marginals and make this is a bivariate
distribution and the quantum analog
here's another example is the quantum
analog this is a quantum of marginal
problem here you are given a default I'd
state so this quantum state which can be
represented by a by D turns oh and
there's again an underlying group action
there every player in this the layers of
these states can change basis for itself
and you ask what the set of marginality
what is the set of marginals of this you
know
objects I'll give you a chance though it
turns out that here you have to be
careful I talked about normalization
here you don't talk about the states you
really want to look at their spectra
doesn't matter why maybe we'll see it
later but anyway each one of these
collections of gradients turns out to be
a convex polytope
so that's another example where their
eyes and testing membership in this
particular you know quantum poly tops is
something that yeah we have algorithms
for so I need to finish
I just want to flesh out some other
examples of moment polytopes each of
them come with a famous name shoehorn
think so diagonals of matrices that are
similar to a given matrix it's not clear
why it's polytopes mostly awake even
convex set of spectral three matrices
with emission matrices whose a plus B
equals C terms of this set of spectra is
a convex polytope and here's another in
which I will not define in all these
cases there are group actions and what
you get out is convex polytopes and it's
not clear at all why in the other two
examples there polytopes and it's not
clear by now it will be clear why our
group actions like I mentioned the
neutron polytopes they arise from Newton
they are convex positive they are moment
proton and it's a matrix intersection
polytope is a moment pointer even though
you never thought about itself so there
are many many examples of these okay and
the last slide is just saying that we
have algorithms so the question we want
to test I'll give you a group action so
it defines the moment polytop and but
anyway
the moment polytop you want to know i
give you a vector and I give you a point
and I'll give you my some tolerance
parameter you want to know whether this
point is in the convex polytope oh it's
epsilon outside it the usual question
and the type of algorithms we have and
we deal more about them two types
alternating minimization algorithms
which converge for normally well in
epsilon and in all other parameters
and those that apply more sophisticated
techniques I would say that more related
to second moment methods in in
optimization but in the geodesic setting
and they converge exponentially fast in
questions but let me conclude so there
are lots of connections between very
aware and as in questions notions and
results algorithms are important this
connection I mentioned between the
analytic and algebraic sites nine theory
is really asymptotic in nature and
quantitative in nature very much like us
and it has and probably requires much
more I think complexity or in terms of
reductions and completeness and stuff
and on the other hand symmetry occurs in
lots of our problems even if we don't
technology there are consequences are
these algorithms that can do things that
we didn't know how to do there are some
problems that are non convex if you can
solve efficiently there are certain
families of quadratic equations that we
can solve this way or in our programs of
exponential size Namid are techniques
that may be useful in optimizations and
there are lots of applications in in
other areas that I will not talk about
and just in terms of open problems you
know the whole project really was about
doing a PRT in polynomial time so we'd
like to do this these are related and
you know talk about this let me just
mention that there are lots more
available in tutorials much longer and
write-ups and videos and so on and
that's just again an advertisement for
my book which talks about other
connections of our field with
mathematics thank you
a couple of questions certify so how
doesn't it doesn't puts a parent equal
to here to the question of NP because
you only long long ago the testing
whether government is positive or zero
essentially in your result you need to
put absolute values to do the same you
asked about the non-negativity the two
things
it's what's always known that if I give
you a non-negative matrix you can test
whether it's permanently zero or
positive this is just a perfect matching
problem of course it alone it points out
and if the matrix has negative values
planet yeah but that's not what I what
we are talking about infected you you
notice maybe the natural question was
whether you can scale it in l2
so in l2 you just care about the
absolute values and it's automatically
positive yeah
they do group action the fixity of the
group action it defines a politics I
want to say that's a very good question
because I want to stress at me until
this I didn't find out about mom mom and
politics I thought that always the
polytope you know is described either by
its facets or by its vertices it turns
out the teal is describing a totally
implicit way and often it's very hard to
find either the facets all the vertices
they are not known but even if they are
not you can test what in some cases you
can test membership in
analysis of the metrics skipping a
quorum based initiative
yeah yeah it's it's it's written up it
so in the it's written up in many of
these papers but even the one that we
had with the little small disk it's just
written in terms of an invariant which
is the permanent the permanent turns out
to be an environment polynomial and
that's how its analyzed we didn't think
of it as an entire podium but the
subsequent paper of the elucidate this
point of it yes what about complexity
situation when you don't close so let's
say you have a matrix we can do it you
check that it's exactly scale operator
is it exactly scale actually for
polynomial I know how to do it but I
need to put some constraint like it's a
really good question
it turns out that there's much more
structure when you look at always closer
than when you look at obits but the
question of orbits is very interesting
for lots of different reasons and yeah I
think that it's just much less developed
and we know that's about it I think
let's go to the break
[Applause]